[Music]
reinvention to me means trying to
reimagine how things are made being
critical of why we're doing the things
that we're doing and questioning the
most basic things that are near and dear
to us for me it's food
I grew up in Texas and I'm Mexican by
heritage and animal protein is was such
a big part of my culture as I learned
more about the food industry I came
across this problem of why are the foods
of the most delicious and the most
accessible oftentimes the ones that are
the worst for you in terms of health and
worse for the planet and I felt that
there was an inherent compromise people
had to make that they couldn't choose
all of them together and that oftentimes
the foods that were the healthiest or
the most sustainable were often the ones
that were the most expensive or the ones
that that were the least accessible that
you couldn't find in any restaurant I
couldn't accept the fact that that that
had to be a reality and I fell in love
with the idea that technology could help
us break that compromise and be able to
build food where you don't have to guilt
people into eating better but that we
can make the right thing the easy thing
when I learned about how incredibly
destructive animal agriculture is to our
environment to the animals into our
human health I realized that we needed
to completely reimagine the way that we
produce protein and that's why I started
the company it's sort of the next
logical progression in how we feed a
world in the 21st century and create a
food system that is fit for today
[Music]
you